pues la manifestación acaba de comenzar
estamos a pocos metros de la Plaza de la
ópera una zona céntrica de aquí de París
la marcha comenzará aquí y se trasladará
hacia la Plaza de la bastilla al final
al finalizar esta jornada se espera una
participación entre 900.000 y un millón
cien mil personas según los servicios de
inteligencia franceses 190 cerca de 190
acciones de protestas alrededor de todo
el país once mil policías desplegados
para garantizar la Seguridad Ciudadana
en una semana y en una jornada que es
decisiva porque recién ayer entró al
parlamento como usted lo mencionaba el a
debate esa ley de reforma de pensiones
de manera que demostrado ya que el
gobierno hace caso omiso a las protestas
en las calles parece o pareciera de
acuerdo con lo que hemos podido
comprobar aquí hoy las personas con las
que hemos hablado que hay que doble que
hay que doblar el paso para presionar al
gobierno a que desista de esta reforma
de pensiones hemos hablado con jóvenes
de 18 años que comenzaron a trabajar
desde los 16 y que nos comunicaban su
pesar por esta reforma su rechazo y su
ira también precisamente porque no se
ven llegando a los 62 años luego de
trabajar por más de 40 en condiciones de
trabajo realmente duras y menos aún
llegar a los 64 como propone esta
reforma del presidente Emmanuel macron